les sanctions américaines ont elles
ralenti la campagne vaccinale au
venezuela pour les autorités
vénézuéliennes
la réponse est oui le pays et sa
compagnie pétrolière pdvsa font l'objet
de sanctions économiques internationales
notamment de la part des états unis
elles se sont intensifiées après la
réélection de nicolas maduro en 2018
jugée frauduleuse par washington
l'économie du venezuela est
essentiellement basée sur l'exportation
de son pétrole
ce mercredi le ministre des affaires
étrangères affirme qu'à cause de ces
sanctions le gouvernement n'a pas pu
acheter autant de doses de vaccin anti
qu'ovide qu'il l'aurait voulu
si les ressources du venezuela n'était
pas bloqué nous aurions pu acheter les
30 millions vaccins dans le pays a
besoin il ya trois mois
non seulement nous aurions les 30
millions de vaccins mais nous aurions
déjà vacciner la moitié de la population
si nous n'avions pas les ressources
bloqués dans le système bancaire
international
le venezuela est contraint d'attendre
les doses issus du dispositif kovacs
chapeauté par l' oms
jusqu'à présent relativement épargnée
par l'épidémie
le pays a vu sa situation sanitaire se
dégrader avec plus de 20000 cas de
contamination qu'ovide 19 pour le seul
mois de mars et les hôpitaux commencent
à être saturé ce mercredi des dizaines
de personnels soignants ont manifesté à
caracas contre le manque de moyens
ils ne fournissent pas de masques ou de
gand et à cause du coc vite 19 nous
devons évidemment avoir des gants et des
masques n'est ce pas s'il nous donne
deux masques aujourd'hui il y en aura
peut-être pas demain
normalement si vous utilisez un masque
vous l'enlever et vous devez les jeter
et mettre le nouveau nom ici vous devez
le réutiliser et ce n'est pas d'idée il
n'y a pas de gants avec lesquels
travailler c'est moi qui achètent mes
propre camp mais l'hôpital ne me donne
pas dedans
le nombre de morts dus coronavirus au
venezuela depuis un an reste faible à
peine plus de 1700 des chiffres
sous-évalué selon des ong locales
à ce jour le pays a reçu 250 mille doses
de vaccin russe spoutnik vais sur les 10
millions convenu avec moscou des doses
du vaccin chinois sinopharm sont
également attendus